marquise chris checking into the ball
game for the mavericks during the parade
with the contest on doncic but he knocks
it down anyway
[Music]
meanwhile have
connected on their last five shots in a
row
just trying to get the officials
attention about something going on at
the other basket
and he did it immediately after making
that last bucket
what's the is it just the net oh the rim
was a little tilted
all right you know good shooters
recognize that stuff yeah yeah good
shooters recognize it so i recognized it
too i was just waiting for luca
did you tell him you told him the room
was tilted right
yeah i saw you that wasn't me
so i think might be we're gonna have a
little time out here and
we're gonna try and adjust the rim
it looked like it was
lean to one side
and you can always
standing
up that is amazing
you know that's the great thing about
tonight's game we get to see the
kobe and toby show reunited again yes
bobon and tobias harris you can see the
hoop is just slanted yeah and he still
made it yeah but it's funny as soon as
he knocks it down the ball he's looking
at like wait that rim looks off yeah
he made it on the low side yeah he made
him lose i knew what he was doing
yeah he was good to get the official's
attention on that
and beaubon
hey he's your fix it up fix it upper guy
what's going on